[Music]
hello there guys this is a very exciting
video because there is a potential link
to description of the second trailer for
spider-man no way home now without
further ado let's just get straight into
the league description strange explains
the spell a bit better peter says that
his identity being revealed is affecting
everyone around him and he has no other
choice someone froze green painted peter
now this scene of green paint being
thrown to peter we actually have seen
the scene leaked before this was from an
alternative cut from the first trailer
anyway back to the trailer description
there's a single shot of peter at what
looks like a courtroom dr strange says
that they shouldn't have messed with the
spell we see a shot of peter talking to
someone at the cafeteria but he doesn't
show who the person is we see the lizard
behind a magical barrier peter stares at
him with a scared look he has pants but
it's the same design from the amazing
spider-man so it says here that they see
the lizard behind a magical barrier so
perhaps this is the barrier from our
leaked and rumored prison where the
villains are trapped inside of and this
is actually apparently that cube that
you can see um that spider-man has
throughout the trailer so apparently
he's helping the villains escape because
green goblin says you know they're going
to be transported back to the world and
killed so you know don't make us have
that fate of death and then peter's
tricked and then you know saves them
sandman is shown as a big sand monster
no kidding we see a fight with electro
at night peter has a black and gold suit
and electro has a yellow and green gas
station suit with yellow electricity
shining as a part of his skin now this
sounds a lot better than his previous
design and amazing spider-man anyway
continuing with the description we see
green goblin explaining to peter that if
strange sends them back to the world
they will die and yes to help them we're
going to see his face and he's wearing a
purple scarf so yeah this was the scene
i was speaking about before there's a
few scenes showing strange chasing peter
peter is holding a cube strange says
that peter doesn't know what he's doing
we see a lot more of the brood scene
with doctor octopus we don't see peter
fighting him only saving people around
him as doc approaches and grabs him mj
and ned are the sanctum that says to
doctor strange that he always wanted to
see a real wizard then that asks if he
can wear the cape and strange makes an
annoyed look now this is the part that
everyone has been waiting for the money
shot of the trailer the big scene of the
trailer the trailer edge of someone
saying that peter will need help and
shows two shadows walking into the
sanctum we only see the shadows on the
ground and the shot of peter with a
confused look the music that plays is a
mix of toby's and andrew's music there
we have it guys toby maguire and andrew
garfield teasing the official trailer so
for me this tease is just enough until
we wait for the movie which releases in
only a month's time also one thing that
i should note is that the version of
this trailer that they saw is apparently
three minutes and 17 seconds long now
apparently there's multiple different
versions of the trailer and this is only
one potential one so this leak is true
this may be of a different trailer that
we may not see because you have to
remember guys for movies that make
several different trailers and only
choose one could this be the one that
they choose potentially but we are not
sure so only time will tell hopefully
we'll get the trailer soon i reckon
sometime next week we'll probably see it
fingers crossed with that out of the way
what do you guys think of this trailer
do you think the t's of just the shadows
and the music is enough or would you
prefer to actually see them physically
in the trailer let me know in the
comment section below and if you did
enjoy this video please like and
subscribe to show your support thanks
for watching guys